Mr debb you see the text from Amber that
says I'm at a coffee meeting now you see
that I do start there so she tells you
at uh at 12 41 PM I'm at a coffee
meeting now we'll be home soon and then
you respond holy crap
no meetings no movies why why do you
deviate from our agreement what species
of meeting just tell me when you get
home did I read that right you did put a
coffee meeting
you didn't want her to take the meeting
that she was taking that day correct
um it seems as though we had an
agreement uh
what seems like we had an agreement to
do something together I'm actually
asking asking what species of mating so
this is not necessarily the angry text
it's just why do you deviate from our
agreement it's not about her doing
films how do you think she got Aquaman
sir you tell her no meetings no movies
because you didn't want her acting you
wanted to control her career correct
objection compound that's yeah sir
misheard had come to me
and she was seriously
seemed to be seriously concerned about
how she was being
portrayed in
in Hollywood
she was she was concerned that
because she had done films where there
was uh
kind of arbitrary nudity and things of
that nature she had voiced to me that
she did not want to be
um she didn't want to be looked upon
that way in the industry she wanted to
be able to escape
the the chains of being objectified
by the Hollywood system which is a
difficult thing for any woman certainly
uh unfortunately but she asked me how
can I avoid being stereotyped as the as
the beautiful blonde who who gets her
breasts out or it goes naked and has to
stop people in in movies uh and I gave
her my
um advice on it on how on how to avoid
it
which I thought was
pretty accurate and uh
it
should
her ambition was stronger than
than
um than what she received from my advice
is is what it was
my advice
that I thought long and hard about
because I did care for her and I did
understand
I didn't want her to have to do that and
early on in my career I I was put in a
position where you know I could have
gone on I could have been
just a guy who was on a TV series for a
couple of years and then you know what
was going to be left of me was uh would
be on lunch boxes and thermoses and
posters and Teen Idol things at night
I've thought that tooth and nail because
I didn't
that's not who I was so I I had had
experienced something similar
in terms of being
looked upon as something that you're not
and so I fought against it
in the very beginning and um
it worked out for me
for you know for a while there and I was
giving it basically the same advice